family if the dad doesn't cheat because
my dad was in that category and like I'm
very proud of the fact that my dad
doesn't drink doesn't smoke doesn't
cheat like he's just a really good dude
and gives me someone to look up to but I
I don't know I it's like if a dude's
worked for 20 years to do this and the
girl agrees to it like who who am I tell
you what to do I think yeah I think that
makes sense right I think what you just
said makes sense is the person the
relationship you're with
um says okay yeah but or if you're
dating an NBA player and you get cheated
on I don't feel bad for you gee like
that girl Jason Derulo's chick who's on
Instagram saying Oh no I got sorry oh no
I got cheated on boo you're dating Jason
Derulo what did you think was gonna
happen he was a hoe before he met you he
met you he's still it's like it's like
when you when you wife a hoe it's like
she was a hoe before you met you yeah
like it's the same sorry okay it's just
it's just like because what bothers me
is girls go in acting all innocent oh I
had no idea but it's like our intuition
is so strong we know when a dude has
options we know when a dude has [__]
so if you should know if you go after a
select type of guy the odds the chance
that he does that is higher and what are
you going to do if he does
if you want to go after that guy that's
something you have to think about yeah
my issue with that with the concept
right because I think they can if they
want to yeah if that's what you want if
that's what you yeah fair enough but
when Kevin Samuels first presented the
idea he he very much said they can
doesn't necessarily mean they will right
yes however
um go to SSO since he's passing I've
seen a lot more red pill people saying
essentially they will and they should
essentially yeah right monogamy is
stupid exactly exactly and the issue I
have with that is because that message
is completely contradictory to what they
say when they they talk about the fact
that those are very men the only reason
why they married a human is for the
children and they might as well have
multiple wives like I mean modern women
are side chicks anyways
but they might as well like get a hug
like but but
like they're doing it like but the
problem with that is the fact that do
you if you saw your dad cheating on your
wife would you respect him on his wife
would you respect that I'd be so sad so
exactly this is the thing but I'm saying
like some girls grow up in that and
they're like good with it like it's
weird I have friends who's like Dad like
that was kind of just yeah yeah like
they don't so they're just like kind of
like that's isn't that how it is in
Nigeria where they're just like that's
how much it depends so a little bit even
I think even my granddad had um one of
my granddads had multiple words but then
this is the problem yeah liked him so
this is what I'm talking about so you
know I mean I wouldn't recommend it I'm
just like
okay do do what you want there's risks
that come with everything yeah so you
pick your poison yeah but but this is
the thing I don't think they consider
yeah and they don't mention this to the
guys when they're saying all this stuff
is like
do you really think your son will
respect you when he sees you cheating on
his mother especially when that Fathers
and Sons always send to cash anyway do
you think that son will respect you when
it comes to when it comes to that no he
won't and so when you're telling men or
suggesting to men that they should be
doing that I don't know like throughout
all of human in history I don't think
all Sons hated their dad I'm not saying
well Sons I'm saying like throughout all
of history human history the most
powerful powerful concubines yeah so I
might
um do you think the boss at Sunset ended
up like that no I'm saying I can't
imagine that all the sons hated their
dads of course it's just it's just how
Society is of course but I think Society
is also very much moved from the world
then if you don't do monogamy then you
get all these unhappy men because
they're you know what I'm saying like I
guess
I'm gonna butcher this but I guess
society's collapse if you have too much
hypergamy and non-monogamy because
they're like the growing number of men
that are sexless just become really
angry and then start to like do bad
things I guess because life is bad I
don't know yeah I mean I can we'll see
it no yeah and and make guarding because
I guess it's bags yeah like um
I I like a lot of fights and stuff
because mate Gardens like when you guard
your mate from other yeah okay yes
actual mates I guess there's like fights
and stuff that happen I don't know I I
forgot Rollo talked about it once like
why monogamy is better on his stream and
it was like because without monogamy
like the there's like a bigger number of
angry men and then people fight over
like because they're all sleeping with
each other yeah I mean yeah I mean we
see all the time in just certain areas
where like I'll stop up another guy
because yeah everything with my girls
yeah yeah you see that a lot yeah I do
think that is an issue people have and
then I'm not trying to say to people oh
God monogamous or whatever live your
life the way you want to live however be
aware of the consequences and I think
those consequences need to be spoken
about more within the Red Bull content
when they're telling men how to live
their lives or when they're telling men
to to be a certain way because they will
end up being
he was you were saying a lot of men
would be unhappy marriages which is true
but then a lot of men are also unhappy
when they're dying alone because they
yeah they stepped around they played the
food but what happens when you're 50 16
you're by yourself it's really sad yeah
it's sad exactly and I I think pushing
narrative that oh yeah once you I think
again this again it's something that
sneaker says which I don't I don't want
to hate on anymore I don't want to seem
like I'm hitting on them but this is
something he says I think he hasn't
thought through the stuff he's saying
you know he's always talking about how
he to an extent he gets fulfillment from
um well the stuff he says implies he
gets fulfillment from having sex with a
lot of girls and just chasing money
after a certain point I think there's a
lot of guys that there are a lot of guys
there
are a lot of guys that say things like
that but it's like
once again how about one if you if you
get fulfillment one in the chat one in
the chat
but then it's once you get past a
certain point in every man who's older
than him has said this to him yeah
except from fresh Myron and fresh yeah
but every man has spoken to him had
debate with him I said that and yeah
he's so confident in his stance that and
he thinks it won't change yet yeah and
he's with the thing that's crazy the guy
I mean Hugh Hefner never got sick of the
house I'm not saying do you think he was
happy when he was there right he looked
pretty happy I'm not gonna on the camera
yeah but you really think when he was
lying by himself no no companion that
was nice he had a lot of good looking
compared like but is that just I I
wouldn't spend it but do you think it's
your guy that's what you'd want no I'm
sick but some guys do some guys do yeah
do you think ganga's Khan I think he was
chilling he was an exceptional man the
exception doesn't make the rules yeah
but I'm saying like some guys I think
NBA players and that's the thing like a
lot of guys don't really have
consequences for it to be honest because
they can like pay they can pay to play
like it's like you think politicians
don't cheat on their wives yeah they
just they the wives kind of know what it
is they get their escorts and you know
they're chilling I don't know
it's just a different I just feel like
as a 25 year old who's not in that world
how could I tell you how to live your
life like you guys work to earn it so
you don't do what you want but this this
is what
this is where I'm coming from because
I'm not saying you should you should be
telling them how to live their lives but
if you're someone who just says the
facts right that's a fact or that's
something that should probably be put
out a little bit more yeah and that
that's the thing that's where I'm coming
at this from whereas I'm not actually
trying to tell people what to do I'm
just trying to show the different yeah
well another another I would say another
thing though is that like women love
guys that cheat so
no it's like okay if y'all if y'all hate
it guys that cheat then why do you date
them
I didn't disagree and I've said this on
YouTube before it's all like not a lot
of them
I've said this let me show you the fact
that girls love being [__] if a man
cheats on you and you go back to him
it's on you
but
I will say you know
when these people talk about
a man being able to marry multiple women
or be with multiple rooms yeah and
talking about women don't mind that's
all that sort of thing oh no do you
think I think they mind